every second of your life you are under
attack billions of bacteria viruses and
fungi are trying to make you their home
still our bodies have developed a super
complex little army with guards soldiers
intelligence weapons factories and
communicators to protect you from well
dying for this video let's assume the
immune system has 12 different jobs for
example kill enemies communicate etc and
it has 21 different cells and two
protein forces these cells have up to
four different jobs let's assign them
here are the interactions now let's make
this understandable
first of all let's add colors to the
jobs now let's illustrate the cells the
central color represents the main job of
the cell while the surrounding ones
represent secondary duties now the
immune system looks like this now the
interactions isn't this complexity just
awesome for this video we will only talk
about these cells and ignore the rest so
what happens in the case of an infection
it's a beautiful day when suddenly a
wild rusty nail appears and you cut
yourself the first barrier of the immune
system is breached your skin nearby
bacteria seized on the opportunity and
enter your wound they start using up the
body's resources and double their
numbers about every 20 minutes at first
they fly under the radar but when a
certain bacterial population is reached
they change their behavior and start to
damage the body by changing the
environment around them the immune
system has to stop them as fast as
possible first of all your guard cells
known as macrophages intervene they are
huge cells that guard every border
region of the body most of the time they
alone can suffocate an attack because
they can devour up to 100 intruders each
they swallow the intruder hole and trap
it inside a membrane then the enemy gets
broken down by enzymes and is killed on
top of that they cause inflammation by
ordering the blood vessels to release
water into the battlefield so fighting
becomes easier you notice this as a very
mild swelling when the metrof ages fight
for too long they call in heavy backup
by releasing messenger proteins that
communicate location and urgency nutria
files leave their patrol roots in the
blood and move to the battlefield the
nutria files fight so furiously that
they kill healthy cells in the process
on top of that they generate barriers
that trap and kill the bacteria they are
indeed so deadly that they evolved to
commit suicide after five days to
prevent them from causing too much
damage if this is not enough to stop the
invasion the brain of the Aleut system
kicks in the dendritic cell gets active
it reacts to the signals of the soldiers
and starts collecting samples from the
enemies they rip them into pieces and
present the parts on their outer layer
now the dendritic cell makes a crucial
decision should they call for antivirus
forces that are a decayed infected body
cells or an army of bacteria killers in
this case anti bacterial forces are
necessary it then travels to the closest
lymph node in about a day here billions
of helper and killer T cells are waiting
to be activated when T cells are born
they go through a difficult and
negated training process and only a
quarter survives the surviving cells are
equipped with a specific setup and the
dendritic cell is on its way looking for
a helper T cell with a setup that's just
right it's looking for a helper T cell
the combined to the parts of the
intruders which the dendritic cell has
presented on its membrane when it
finally finds one the chain reaction
takes place the helper T cell is
activated it quickly duplicates
thousands of times some become memory to
cells that stay in the lymph node and
will make you practically immune against
this enemy some travel to the field of
battle to help out and the third group
goes on to travel to the center of the
lymph node to activate a very powerful
weapons factory like the T cells they're
born with a specific set up and when a
b-cell and the T cell with the same set
up meet hell breaks loose the B cell
duplicates rapidly and starts producing
millions of little weapons they work so
hard that they would literally die from
exhaustion very fast here helper T cells
play another important role they
stimulate the hard-working factories and
tell them don't die yet we still need
you keep going this also ensures that
the factories die if the infection is
over so the body doesn't waste energy or
hurt itself but what is produced by the
B cells you've heard of them of course
antibodies little proteins that are
engineered to bind to the surface of the
specific intruder there are even
different kinds of antibodies that have
slightly different jobs the helper T
cells tell the plasma cells which type
is needed the most in this particular
invasion millions of them flood the
blood and saturate the body meanwhile at
the site of infection the situation is
getting dire the intruders have
multiplied in number and start hurting
the body guard and a tech cells fight
hard but also die in the process helper
T cells support them by ordering them to
be more aggressive and to stay alive
longer but without help they can't
overwhelm the bacteria but now the
second line of defense arrives billions
of antibodies flood the battlefield and
disable lots of the intruders rendering
them helpless or killing them in the
process
they also stun the bacteria and
them an easy target their back is built
to connect to killer cells so they can
connect and kill the enemy more easily
macrophages are especially good at
knowing up the bacteria which antibodies
have attached to now the balance shifts
in a team effort the infection is wiped
out at this point
millions of body cells have already died
no big deal the losses are quickly
replenished most immune cells are now
useless and without the constant signals
they commit suicide so is not to waste
any resources but some stay behind the
memory cells if this enemy is
encountered ever again in the future
they will be ready for it and probably
kill it before you even notice this was
a very very simplified explanation of
parts of the immune system at work can
you imagine how complex this system is
even at this level when we ignore so
many players and all the chemistry life
is awfully complicated but if we take
the time to understand it we always
encounter endless wonders and great
beauty